andrew you acted in middle school high
school
college yeah what made you want to come
to la and think that you could do it as
a career
uh so i was born in l.a moved to san
diego as a kid
and my earliest memories of me wanting
to act
um i i just
have never known anything different it's
just what i was going to do for the rest
of my life and
fortunately being born here and
understanding the system
of la was was a huge plus so
it's it's just never been something i
questioned it was just always
been something i was gonna do and and i
didn't have to come
to la i could just be here
because i have always been here so yeah
it's just always been something i was
going to do
period and i never thought anything
different
yeah you said something really
interesting at the system
what is that system la's a system has a
system you have to understand that la is
smaller than people think it's spread
out for sure
um but uh you know
you have to get used to how things run
here um how
traffic works how when you have a job
how to get there and and i mean it's
those it's the living details
right i think a lot of people come here
that i talk to and i tell them take a
year to get used to things don't worry
about making a move
in the industry don't move about getting
auditions don't worry about all this
stuff
understand how la works you know
understand that
um it's gonna take an hour to get
anywhere
um if you're lucky understand that your
social life
is those you work with and when you want
your social life you have to plan for
that
it's not like new york where you can
walk down the street and hit seven bars
in 30 minutes it's not like that it's
it's different and
everyone here is a working professional
and you have to prepare for that and so
understanding that system and growing up
and it really was super helpful
because then i could just get into the
work and worry about that kind of stuff
because
you know living here is second nature
obviously for me so
what what made you want to act i know
you said it was just i don't know
you never saw like a movie like et or
something you're like
i just remember being i want to be
elliot being born and wanting to do it
my earliest memory is just wanting to do
it i do remember
um watching the movie life with mikey
with michael j fox
okay uh i remember that yeah he plays an
agent
in the film and he finds this girl on
the street who's like hustling
and he's like she's a great actor let's
get her in commercials that was the
first time i understood that i needed an
agent um but i
ever since i mean i was born i couldn't
tell you what it was
i just was born just knew wanted to do
it did anybody try to talk you out of it
never
never never once that's great parents
family relatives
friends all of them have been super
supportive just like yeah this is what
he's gonna do
and that's that and they've always
supported me i've never heard anything
negative
that's wonderful yeah you said something
really interesting about the friendships
um
are the people that you work with and
one thing that's so fascinating is
everybody has like these side jobs
and so sometimes it's hard to like get
together with people especially on the
weekends
because that's when a lot of people are
doing their side job
you know and so that was one thing
that's really interesting because you
don't coming from other places
maybe there's more of a nine to five
life yeah maybe not now
maybe i'm thinking of other times but no
i think so i think so
absolutely um i just know that the way
la's built
it is so spread out that if you want to
get anywhere
you have to plan for it and it's just
easier to make friends with those you
work with
you know they you see them all the time
and you
and this was a really hard lesson for me
you know when i went to college
you're you see your friends every day
you hang out all night you party all
night whatever
and then you go to finals super
exhausted and that's that
but then when you come here it's like oh
people are working people are doing
things and you
and you have to be prepared for that and
you're not going to be out until three
in the morning every day
a you're gonna be going to bed and then
getting up and going to work and then
working on your career and working on
your things and
and then meeting your friends once a
week for dinner if you're lucky
you know because everyone's busy and i
like that it's a different phase of life
for me it's just it's where i'm at now
and it feels good it feels like the
right place
where did you go to college just a small
community college in orange county
called saddleback yeah oh yeah yeah i've
heard of that
amazing school for great things yeah i
love it
and did you take um acting or you got an
aaa or what did you
so i i studied i majored in psychology
and social behavior i decided to
quit acting forever about six months in
i begrudgingly auditioned for one of the
plays
that was it i was like okay i'm gonna do
this again for the rest of my life
and dropped all my classes took every
theater course i could
every screenwriting course i could and
overloaded everything and then finished
those classes i didn't technically
graduate
um because i just dropped all dropped
all my major stuff i just went right
into every acting class i could
and got back into it so i took like a
six month hiatus i guess
i don't know okay yeah and then
sorry how long have you been in l.a uh
like i've been back for about three and
a half years now
oh i see okay because you you so like i
was i
technically grew up in san diego um and
then
moved to orange county for school
went to saddleback studied there and
then right after i finished all the
courses i could take
i moved right back up here and just went
full board
nice yeah it's a really pretty campus
isn't it if i'm thinking of something
right it's small
but it's nice it's pretty yeah they're
really developing it i like it a lot
it's a
great education i mean all my professors
were from yale and juilliard and
so i got all their insights for a very
small price
yeah no a lot of people are doing the
whole two years at community college and
then transferring yeah
especially now yeah i knew i knew i
wasn't going to transfer i knew i was
just going to come up here and start
beating the streets up and making films
and acting and writing and doing
everything i could to get in
so your first day back what was that
like after your
you know you've come you've got your 60
units or whatever it was at saddleback
and then you come here
what was that like the first day super
awesome
um it's it's a funny story i
i sat outside this airbnb my friend and
i were renting for two weeks
uh because we didn't have a place yet
and i sat in my car and i said i'm going
to do this if
even if i have to live in my car to do
this i will i'll never let it get to
that point but if i had to i would
and everything changed after that you
know my roommate and i we
we lived in this airbnb for like two
weeks and then
the lady had this like this uh
shed that she had turned into like a
photography studio really small
square she had no running water we lived
in that for three months
no space it was crazy and then we moved
up to this
we subleased to this apartment we shared
a room there
and then we moved into our own place
then moved into a bigger place so we've
been
steadily climbing ever since interesting
yeah that's cool that i mean she lets
you
sounds like she was a creative obviously
if she's yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah she was an awesome
awesome landlord for sure super great
person
but yeah it was just a little tight a
little tight living in that box
would you say you're a confident person
or more realistic
super confident super confident yeah um
i humbly confident i try to remain
um my definition of realism is way
different uh realistic to me is yeah go
out and make a movie for no money
that it happens just do it uh realism
for me is
yeah you have nothing move out to la and
be a filmmaker be an actor be an artist
whatever you want to do
so my definition of realism is not
society's definition i think and i'm
very confident in that
yeah i really believe in just doing it
going for your dreams
did you see that on someone did you see
it in an artist that you admired or
or you know watch the documentary on
something no um
i just didn't know any other way i
i uh maybe i saw it
my dad is is realistic according to
society's standards you know you
you grow up and you you go to school and
you get a job
and you go after your dreams and you you
know pay for your bills and this type of
that
my dad's super supportive of my dream um
but he i think he learned how to accept
my way of thinking which is just like
um yeah things will get done i'll get my
rent paid don't worry about it i'll get
my
my bills paid don't worry about it but
i'm also going to make this movie
and i'm just going to do it whether
anybody helps or not it's going to get
done
period and
i think going full board into something
you have to you have to be sure of it
you know and uh it took a long time to
develop confidence confidence i think is
a learned habit
um all my our 20s anyone's 20s are just
a hectic mess i'm sure mine were and uh
you know that's where i learned how to
say yes and say no
and be confident in decisions i was
making it took a long time
to learn that habit what's great too is
now there's like these side gigs and i
know there's
talk on well it's actually not as
lucrative as you think and and that's a
whole nother discussion but
when i moved here there wasn't that so
that's what's nice about
you can be a creative and then do these
like side hustle jobs
that they didn't really totally have
right
back then and so yeah i mean you know
there's so many opportunities now
i always say is money will come there's
so many opportunities to
have an income um and today there are so
many different kinds of side hustles
that allow
a creative to spend more of his time
doing what they want to do
creating writing working acting painting
dancing whatever it is
and then they go to their day job at
night or in the day or whatever and um
they come home and they work on their
art and i
i think it's a great time to be an
artist super great time so many
opportunities
to to be an artist for sure and maybe
it's just because i live in la and i was
raised here so that's all i see
but yeah i see it everywhere just
everyone's an artist
everyone's doing something and they're
still paying their bills
now that you've been back in la what
three years
how has your perspective on acting and
and
being here changed or is it all still
the same well it's changed
for sure because as humans we change and
evolve and grow
hopefully hopefully
[Laughter]
there's way less fear than i used to
have there's way
i used to have expectations that la was
something impossible to break into um
that the industry was this this
untouchable dream
um but with all the streaming services
that are available with all the um
online platforms that are available
there's been so much more opportunity
for work
for for any creative um i mean
films are being made every day pilot
season is
all year you know because because
these streaming services are just buying
so much work
and buying so many creatives to work on
these things and
there's no seasons anymore i mean there
are there are
but it's just different because when you
when you release on netflix or or
hulu or amazon prime it it can be year
round
so that has been super helpful because
that took all the fear away there's
always something being made
and there's for the independent artist
there's always something you can make
and always an
opportunity for it to be seen because of
all these platforms so
that's a huge difference and that
really made me more confident in the
whole la system
and two when you meet people that have
booked something or you see they have a
national commercial
you're like oh wow like that's someone i
know
and yeah yeah they're doing it you know
then it makes it seem possible
absolutely absolutely a friend of mine
he i mean
i see him on commercials all the time
and it's
it's just dual it's just now more doable
than ever
a lot of my friends direct commercials
or direct music videos and
and they tell me how they got started
and whatnot and it's just like i said
way more doable than it's ever been
and it's super super uh
a super warm feeling to know that
in the last few years i believe and
please stop me if i'm wrong uh you've
begun to write
and direct and produce your own projects
do you wish you'd done that earlier or
did you come in to it in the right time
you feel like it's naturally
evolved yeah i think it naturally
evolved i think came in at the right
time for sure
um in my early 20s it just there's no
way
you know as a young kid like that you're
just trying to figure so many things out
and you don't know yourself and you're
trying to know yourself
and having the foundation of wanting to
be an
actor was always there but
today's triple threat it's very
different than it was in the 50s where
you know you had to be able to sing
dance and act you know it's very
different today
being a triple threat is being able to
write your own stuff produce your own
stuff direct your own stuff star in your
own stuff
and then distribute your own stuff and
that if you can do all of that
efficiently and proficiently um you're
gonna get seen
that's that's the neutral threat so
coming into
directing and writing um and bringing
that
into my my wheelhouse as um
it came at the right time for me now
because i think it's
it's necessary to be able to do all
those things now as an artist
for sure yeah you talked about sort of
like the crazy 20s and
i think some people are able to just
kind of like know what they want
and and others there's other things
they're working on
and without going too much down this
path also too there's a lot of people
preying on you when you're in your 20s
and
it and i've talked about this before but
if you don't if you're not used to
getting compliments or
if compliments make you feel like a
million dollars which they do with
everybody
you're going to find that element coming
out
when you walk down the street yeah when
you go to a coffee shop and
people seem legitimate and i think it's
being able to sniff out
yes a predator or who's wasting your
time they may not even be a predator
right and that takes some time
that takes a lot of learning how to read
people
and learning how to um
shuffle through all the bs and and know
who is just giving you a business card
and know knowing who can potentially
advance your career
i found in my experience when i meet
people who
can potentially aid my career in a way
it's best to just have a good
conversation
don't worry about pitching yourself
don't worry about pitching your projects
just get to know them as a person
chat talk tell stories anecdotes get to
know them
ask questions about them because people
love talking about themselves
and then ninety percent of the time i
found that they've wanted to get my
information and find out what i'm doing
afterwards
and then you have those people who have
no problem telling you everything about
themselves without even being asked
and they always have this way of talking
themselves up just a bit bigger than
they are
and and you can you can tell you can
read them you know
well okay and then you just move on from
those people
um but because there's like i said
earlier there's so much work being
created today
you just have to know who's who's going
to finish the work
and who's just going to start the work
does that make sense
it does yeah and then and then also too
if you take it down
the sort of predatory route there are
people that are
so skilled at reading people and they
know
they know what's going to get you and if
you're young and impressionable oh my
gosh
it's so so and if you don't have a
jiminy cricket sitting on your shoulder
saying
no this person's no good for you that's
very difficult and i think we're seeing
unfortunately for men and women
it it happens across the board i think
equally that
people i mean and it's human nature i
think to fall
prey to that because we do want to know
that we're special
and and some of those people are really
good at knowing where to zero in
i think it takes a lot of time yeah you
have to be careful
when you're young and informable because
it takes a long time to learn confidence
like i said earlier it takes some time
and when you can get to that point where
a compliment
is simply an addition to your happiness
it's not the source of your happiness
and and you have to be able to have
everything in hollywood be
additions to your life you have to own
your resolve
you have to be able to say i'm good with
or without it and then when you get a
compliment you say thanks and you
take it as truth and and you're grateful
for it but
that confidence will will steer those
kinds of people away who just want to
take advantage or prey on you
because they know that they're not going
to get anything from you because
you they won't be the source of your
happiness right then and you're not
afraid of
losing an opportunity if you will right
i think that's another issue that young
young stars or young hopeful stars have
is they're so afraid of losing an
opportunity they're so afraid of
losing this potential thing whether it's
an agent or
or a manager or a job you know when when
it's
the agent the manager they're just a
joke and they're not going to do
anything for you but they're so afraid
that it could be the one
that they take it when you can when you
can confidently say you know what
no something else will come down the
line that's when you're set
that's that's the best place you can be
as a beginning actor as a
long time actor or artist being able to
say no to things
because you know in your heart that it's
not the best place
and you're not afraid of losing an
opportunity because when you say no to
certain things
that leaves room for the good things to
come in
you know i like that that's really good
i like the fact that you said i'm good
with or without this yes
that's that takes a lot yeah being happy
and not happy because happy
and i have an agent happy and i have a
movie happy and
i have a relationship not happy because
i have an
agent or a movie or relationship you
know that's super important
to have that gusto here in la super
important
i'm going to take your advice good i i
needed to hear that today so thank you
you're welcome when the student is ready
yes yes
andrew will appear that's really good
because you're right because we've
especially
everything so external here and so we
all kind of oh
i like that car oh i want to do that you
know and and so
everything's out there and so yeah it's
not an
easy thing to have it be about inside
inside for sure it takes a long time to
get to that point to where you're not
afraid of saying no to things that could
be something
you know and just patiently waiting and
working hard
to to make all the right opportunities
happen because the opportunities will
come
when you have everything lined up and
you're doing everything you can
first the right things will come
you have a project that you just
finished shooting and that you
wrote starred in directed
produced and this was before that you
had a short
what's that right a few shorts you had a
few shorts okay so this is a feature
yeah um when did you begin writing
it's called come into your own yeah come
into your room um
i wrote the initial treatments to
12-page treatment
maybe 2013. um
i had an idea went home that night wrote
it
the treatment one night and then sat on
it uh finished school
uh once that was done moved to la and
when i was
comfortable again here that's when i
started riding the project
yeah oh so this is from the saddleback
years it's from the saddleback years oh
my gosh
okay so so it sounds like it's a
personal it's very personal
or no it's not okay that's an idea
interesting yeah okay
that's the story so the story follows a
young gay man who is
stuck in the rut of monotony he's tired
of his current relationship so he
decides to like
stir the embers in his life and try
something drastic just to feel
something and that leads to certain
consequences
and uh he has to learn through those
things oh yeah we can't say what they
are right it'll give away the
um
he he makes some he makes choices which
is most important for that character the
character makes choices
and the choices lead to lead to events
that are good and bad
obviously it's life but he makes
i think has any young 20 year old
learning how to make choices is
important that's where this character's
in is like he's learning how to make
decisions learning how to make choices
and i know that when humans i for sure
are stuck in a rut sometimes we do
drastic things you know i'm just gonna
quit my job today
so i do it or i'm just gonna break up
with you today so i do it and then i go
do something crazy
just to feel something totally opposite
of that and that's what this character
goes through he
is so burnt out on the the monotony that
he's lived his whole life
he just does something crazy something
different and um he goes
full board into it but it hurts some
people along the way
and he has to he has to learn that he
can take time to make decisions
you know is his life too safe his life
is way too safe
he makes he's been taught how to live
safe he says that in the film i just
never taught how to do anything
different or dangerous
and um he he wants to just
explore try things you know
be scared he's never been scared
you know he's just been bored and he's
scared of being bored
you know so he does some crazy things
interesting yeah
and what's the character has an
interesting name yeah the character is
named liram illario
okay so lirum um i believe
it's been so long to discover these
names i think lirum is
has something to do with being a free a
free man a free person
and then allerio i believe is is a
version of a latin version of the word
eagle
you know he he i i've been taught i
don't know if it's totally accurate but
i've been taught that eagles are like
the only kind of
bird who will fly in the midst of a
thunderstorm
and he he takes that that analogy to
heart he wants to be something that will
just try something dangerous like that
and so i always like characters that
have to grow into their names
and he has to do that himself so yeah
lyra malario
a free man who wants to fly on the wings
of eagles that's kind of what his name
means
in a thunderstorm in a thunderstorm yeah
why did you write it i didn't realize
until recently why i wrote it
um on the service level i i
want to be a maker of my destiny i don't
want to wait for i don't wait for
anything i just do things
and i wanted work so i made work i wrote
a film to have a film done
future um i wanted to be out there
i wanted to have a calling card but
internally i didn't realize like i said
till recently that
the theme of coming into your own which
is the title coming to your own
is something everyone has to go through
i went through it in my 20s
we have to make decisions we have to
learn how to act we have to learn how to
grow and communicate and gain confidence
and
i realized at the time the initial idea
came to me that's exactly where i was
i was quitting one thing and trying
something new and then going back to the
thing i quit and quitting the thing i
was trying something new and and
trying to figure out my place in this
whole crazy thing called life
and um subconsciously i had an idea of a
young 20 year old doing that
and and wrapping that story up they're
absolutely wrapping that theme
of coming into your own coming of age in
a story about a young gay man
who decides to break up with his
boyfriend
in the middle of the proposal and then
try dating a young girl for the first
time in his life
and doing something drastic something
he's never done um
and like i said though that leads to
consequences you know
it teaches him one how to be honest with
himself be honest with others be honest
with
everyone around him and and figure out
how to how to guide his own life
and not be not live off the guidance
his parents have taught him to do you
know so that's where i think
subconsciously it came from but actually
producing the thing was just because as
as the filmmaker you we need to be
producing work
all the time we need to be it's just in
our blood
you know you think too i mean this is
nothing against orange county but
did it was so safe there it's very safe
and sanitized
yeah i mean it's a beautiful place um
but but do you think because you're
around that
too i mean i'm just no words in your
mouth no
i had come from a very dangerous very
dangerous living
when the idea came to me i was living
out of state
i was in a very very bad relationship
my mom had to literally buy a plane
ticket and drag me home
it was bad and that's why i decided
i'm done with this life i'm going to do
something totally different
um and then interesting i went back to
what is truly comfortable which is my
art my career my craft and went back to
what is happy and safe
for me which is my career um
and i think that's partly why it's
stemmed you know he
he does he does something dangerous he
doesn't mean different for himself
something that is out of character for
him and uh
he ends up realizing that and kind of
going back to what he always knew
okay so it was the opposite yeah it was
the very opposite
thing was very opposite wow interesting
it was a very scary time sure yeah
that's fine
i have no problem talking about it but
yeah it was crazy it's up to you i mean
i think some some people have had that
and others
i don't want to say they've been
sheltered but that's basically the word
right
and i think that this character totally
was okay yeah i grew up with a lot of
people like that i wasn't but
i saw kids that they could only watch
pbs yeah
by a certain time same with him what's
interesting about this story
is it if the story follows a young gay
man
in a world where that is just very much
open and accepted all over the place i
mean obviously being in l.a
you know we're fighting for that kind of
equality and whatnot um
but in this in this story it's just yeah
he's gay who cares he's just what he is
he's always been that way his parents
have always known that's what it is no
big deal
um and which i think is a good place to
be
just be you right that's what he is but
his his qualms are as with how he was
raised it's it's it's
you know he says in the script you know
i i've i've been from my front door to
my backyard
you know he's never seen outside his
neighborhood he was born and raised in
la he
went to school and had a cree and
developed a career he was supposed to
develop and
and he he dated the guy he was supposed
to date
you know he found the success his
parents wanted him to find
and that that's what drove him to say
i'm i need to do something
crazy and he decides to do that
and um it it shocks him
you know it shocks his system which is
what he wants but
not in the best way possible right he
hurts people along the way doing so
interesting yeah i mean
yeah living i think i feel like in your
20s you can you can be that
wild person and then especially if you
have other responsibilities even if you
don't have kids it's just harder
yeah but you know some people don't come
into their own until
60s there's a character in the film his
mentor the mentor character who
comes into his own late into his 40s
you know they both kind of help each
other realize that the character's name
is ted
and he works with lira he's this
man-child
he works at this they work at this small
startup um a health beverage company
and and this young this 45 year old guy
is working with all these young 20 year
olds and trying to be cool and trying to
be their friend
and trying to be hip with their lingo
and trying to be a millennial and he's
just so
not and he realizes that through helping
this young kid figure himself he figured
oh you know
i'm an adult and i i can be this father
figure and i can just
love myself as i am just a
gentle man who it works with this group
of young kids but i don't have to try
and be this young guy i can just be who
i am
so yeah it's true and then the every
character i hope is trying to come into
their own with this film
no matter what age no matter what age
and that's
i hope how we all are in life i i
fortunately was able to figure all that
mess
out in my 20s and now i feel better than
ever yeah they're definitely people who
are learning late into their late into
their 50s
you know right that's totally fine
beyond totally fine
it's totally fine as long as you're
progressing as long as you are coming
into your own
does it talk about sort of like either
family or cultural
pressures or whatever um or no
no what's interesting is is his
character is hispanic
and he comes from a very latin family
his dad
uh very much of an american white man
his mom hispanic now they're just
mentioned in the film
his mom is very latin he says he wears
big jewelry and is very colorful in the
life of the party because that's how my
my latin family is you know they're
very colorful and um but
for the subtext of the character his his
mom
came and decided to live the american
dream you know with her husband and
you know taught her son to grow up and
go to college and get the nine to five
and date the right person
and be married by you know 26 or 27 and
have kids when you're 32 and this and
this and this and this and follow the
order
um and that's what he was taught by his
parents and
so it was it was cultural influences
according to the american dream you know
is what is what his parents wanted him
to live
as a hispanic man right
he tells this young so so the the girl
he dates in this film is is a white girl
who was raised all over the world speaks
multiple languages
um grew up in and was born in concepcion
chile
went to tokyo studied there and all over
the world because
her father was in politics and just
traveled he was a diplomat
and she he sees this white this this
white american woman
who was culturally aware
and speaks languages and is so not what
the surface looks like
and he of being a latin man is so
not that he's just a white american
and and and he wants to
be in touch with this culture he wants
to be in touch with um
his his hispanic roots he speaks spanish
because he was taught that as his first
language but
it's just words for him it doesn't mean
anything
you know there's no romance in the
beauty of the language for him
like there is for her you know and so
there's that there's that
interesting dynamic between the two
where you see this white young girl who
is
culturally culturally relevant and then
this hispanic boy who is not
you know and i wanted to touch on that
for those reasons
it's always interesting when we see
someone and it's not even where there's
like a physical attraction it's just
you're like i want to be like you could
be male or female oh that makes me want
to cry when you say that
because that is exactly what this film
is about this film is not about him
figuring out his sexuality he's a gay
man he knows it
but he's in love with what she
represents
he dates her because he wants to steal
culture from her
that's his that's his whole thing he
loves everything she
is he may not be physically attracted to
her
but he loves her history
and the languages she speaks and all the
earth she's touched in his life you know
you know she's touched the ground where
he's only dreamed of
he re he's a he's a research developer
for this health beverage company
and he researches the world behind the
computer screen
and he's just envious of that and so
that's why he dates hers because he's in
love with the idea of those things
it's so amazing that you say that
because that's exactly what happens to
him
well they say sometimes that's why we
fall for certain people is because
we actually almost want to be them
because they're like
living what we thought and we want to
not not even what they're doing but like
who they are whether they're just
they're not bound by certain oh my gosh
you know it makes me so emotional when
you say that because it's like
that's so exactly what the character is
that's amazing that's amazing that you
say that
well also too it can be i mean we're
getting really deep here but why
somebody could be jealous of someone too
yeah oh my god
it might not and it could be again male
or female
you the opposite gender but you could
just see something in them
and you won't allow that in yourself and
so instead of like
you just like i hate that person oh my
gosh and and
you know because am i have you ever i've
i felt that when i was younger i would
see certain people and then i started to
realize like
they had troubles too and they weren't
perfect
but some people i don't know if they
it's so easy to like
you could do that with celebrities so so
true so true in fact
her character is so different from him
she sees in his life
this rooted man this guy who grew up
with a stable family
a mom and a dad and sister the white
fence everything
went to the same school his whole life
had a best friend pets
those everything that he has she wants
but they can't give each other that and
that's what creates the conflict
right um but it's so true they both feel
that way
i'm so jealous of you you've had this
great family relationship
her parents are split up um yours didn't
that happens today parents stay together
what
and she wants that so bad she wants to
have
you know she wants to live in one home
for the rest of her life and he's like
no i want to live on a boat and travel
the world
so it's it's amazing that you pick that
out in
in humans because that's so what these
characters are amazing
yeah i think that people as like you
know because if you didn't have let's
say the white picket fence
and you do see someone that has it like
this like stable thing you're like oh
wow i wish i could have that
and they look at you as maybe like oh
wow you don't have all the pressures i
have and i mean the grass is always
greener right
right right wow that's amazing
did you read any screenwriting books
while you were writing yeah
um dialogue by robert mckee
story by robin mckee save the cat
uh pretty much all of them all the
famous ones
because i needed to learn you know more
better formatting
um stuff like that um watched a lot of
uh watched a lot of videos um learning
uh how to appropriately write character
arcs and development story arc and
and those kinds of things so yeah i
studied a lot of a lot of different
things
and did you already write the screenplay
before you started reading the books or
uh i had started because when i went to
school i had i had taken screenwriting
classes so i knew how to
do it but um the the
the books obviously very much helped
tighten everything up
you know helped solidify
what i had already known and
give me confidence that okay i'm on the
right path as far as
structure is concerned um how i'm on the
right path as far as how this character
should evolve and develop
i truly believe in formula and i think
these books offer really solid formula
that you can just color by number you
know i have an idea i have a story this
character needs to be this at this point
uh so let's get to that point and uh so
they've
been super helpful to tighten everything
up so you outlined obviously because you
said you you came
to treatment treatment okay yeah i'm a
free i i'm a free writer honestly i get
my do my best work when i just
write um i i don't
i don't once once the story's out then i
take time to really
flesh characters out which i guess is
outlining
um but i wrote the treatment in a night
i i didn't
i didn't think about anything i didn't
let my
my rule i didn't let rules get in the
way
just just wrote it and then is when i
went back and said okay this character
gets to that point because of this so i
guess i outlined a little bit later
but not initially and where did you
write it where were you when you were
writing
i wrote the treatment i wrote in orange
county this is when i was in school
um at your apartment in my apartment
yeah my house and then
uh when i came to la i
wrote the script in my room yeah i i set
up my computer to my big tv and just
wrote to the tv yeah just right oh nice
so like huge fonts
huge font screen just wrote it on the tv
that was awesome it's good on the eyes
yeah oh my gosh
yeah it's way better and then how long
did it take you to finish
total would you say i wrote the uh the
first draft in two and a half months
sat on it for six months so i get a
fresh look and then went and did
uh the rewrite in about three weeks and
so about three and a half three
and a half months to write the whole
thing um paid for
writers to what what's the script
conference yeah paid for coverage
got coverage got notes i learned
probably the biggest lesson i've learned
is that everyone has an opinion
and everyone will tell you their version
of the story so as long as you trust
your gut it's great to get notes it's
great to get notes but trust your gut
first because
you're going to get a thousand different
notes and people are going to tell you
oh
why try this why don't you try that or
try this try that and
i think honestly i used maybe four or
five
of the notes that i got from everyone
who did coverage because
it was just so vast you know that was
really
that was a really hard experience for me
was knowing
what to take that's a great note that's
not a great note
that's okay that's that was where the
work came in
that was where the work came in was
fixing according to what they were
offering
and knowing that you know what i don't
have to use that note
or that one's really good i will use it
and being okay with that
you know but that was really i think
where the most work came in was
that i would love to hear how you found
the script consultants without giving
their names
um so i went to the blacklist i
submitted there
they responded with a lot of different
notes um i went to
uh i applied for the nickels fellowship
they gave me a ton of notes back
um i went to writer's workshops
locally in lm and you can just research
a bunch um
and i met other writers there who had
who had credits under their belt said
hey can
can you do some coverage for me they
were always willing to
you know paid them a little bit of money
and they were always grateful to
to just give me notes and um that's
where i found most my coverage was from
the writing workshops
is one networking with people in person
and doing it that way and there's
millions you can research
online millions do you mind me asking
how much you paid them
i'm just what's fair i mean yeah no i
because obviously
you know the i mean they weren't
professional like a lot of them were
professional but a lot of them weren't
professional coverage
um i just know that they had credits
under their belt and so
i would just offer you know i would say
hey 100 bucks does that work for you
and they're like yeah sure and you know
a couple weeks or three weeks later i
would get some notes back and they were
always really fast turnarounds i was
surprised
you know they always dedicated some time
to it which is great
um but yeah i just offered what i could
you know and that's what another thing
is is ask
ask first people are always willing to
help i got this film done because i just
asked
first you know and then saying hey what
what can what can we do what kind of
thing can we work everyone in ellie
negotiates
just get comfortable with that language
the negotiation language
and yeah just offer them what you can
and see what they can do and
be be just be grateful for what whatever
you can get you know just be
grateful and uh that's that's pretty
much what i found
how many uh coverage reports did you get
back
like six to eight maybe solid ones and
then
wow and then the rest were just from
friends and and people who i knew
growing up who i
knew were in the industry but really
like six days solid ones that were like
okay you're a solid professional
um who who i can like trust
you know because you know you have your
friends read it they're going to either
tell you it's great or they're going to
say
it's awful rework it you know they're
not going to be specifics but
i say coverage is great because they can
give you specifics
you know so you had six to eight people
that you met
yeah that emitted these workshops and
stuff were great great at doing it yeah
yeah and so that's where um
each time they gave you notes back did
you
i like how how did that work when you
got their notes
i'm sure you probably looked at it
whether you considered it now
you did it yeah yeah absolutely um
the pattern i found is that everyone
like i said would
typically give you give you narrative
notes
and and i i was looking for more
structural notes
um things like does this character
a get to point z
by this time you know and the dialogue
makes sense
and you know i i wasn't necessarily
looking for someone to
to change the narrative as far as like
this guy meets this girl and decides to
do this with her
um but i got a lot of that i got a lot
of people like well why don't you why
does it have to be this why don't you
try this
and those were the kind of notes that i
was like valid
but that's not where the story is going
this is the narrative this is the path
it's on
does does point a get to point b does
point b
get to point c and uh that's kind of the
formula i found that's kind of the
routine i found yeah so i would read the
notes
and then um uh pick and choose
and that was the best part you're
getting to pick and choose what worked
and what didn't
you know and you don't have to feel bad
that they they understand
they understand if you don't pick their
note that's fine well they got paid they
got paid
yeah it's whatever get over it yeah yeah
any advice to people on hiring a script
consultant what if they've never done it
and there's someone where they can hire
them at a reasonable price
it's not like this you know yeah for
sure
definitely the blacklist i mean it's
they're super well known
and they their professionals are so good
so good
um they they get back to you fairly
quickly
um and they always
offer great advice they don't just say
this is wrong but they say this is what
you could also do to
fix that um they they
it's not just i mean it's comp they give
you great compliments too
they score you so i would say look at
the blacklist first because it's a
really good introduction to script
coverage for sure
and then once you're working with the
script consultant anything
any do's and don'ts any red flags any
anything that
you really want to encourage more of um
be open for collaboration as writers uh
we're always very precious of our work
you know
but be open know that you are going to
fix things
and be excited to cut be excited to fix
um it's really hard it's so much easier
said than done
to like cut something but i remember
when i made my first cut
suddenly like the doors opened and i was
like cutting everything i was like oh
let's cut that and let's cut that and
let's just make it streamline it you
know and then it got fun
you know but it took a little it took a
little
movement with someone else saying hey
but this is why it could work
you know and just be open just be open
for
the the consultant to give you the right
again you don't have to take their
advice
but just be open for it and if you're
not open for it just pretend you are
because they're doing you a service you
know
so then basically don't hire a
consultant just so they can tell you
it's great
be open to customers that's for sure
yeah um
we will fluff our own egos enough so
don't just hire a consultant just to
hear you're great because they will tell
you
you're not they will tell you things to
fix
be open for that again you don't have to
take the notes
um they may be way off base because it's
just an opinion
from another another writer a working
professional
but they do have valid points and just
take those
just say thank you and and see how it
could work
um try and play with it in your head
give it a give it a chance
you know okay well how could this work
let's see if we do point a to point d
and if we get it to that way
sure let's try that um and if it doesn't
sit right in your gut
um you'll know but again don't listen to
your gut because of your ego though
you know i just has to be this way
because this is the way i wrote it
originally
you know trust trust your gut as you
step aside and say
this will be the best for the story this
will be the best for the characters
and again it is your story you know it
better than anyone
um but they're just trying to help you
get it to the best point it can be so
just just be open for it just be open
for it
any red flags like what if you're not
meshing
you don't have to mesh you know if
you're not meshing with a person that's
fine
you don't have to uh you're there for
business
you're there for work as far as red
flags you know i mean
i don't know i don't know um
i've never i don't know it sounds like
you had all positive feelings
experiences i mean if they were a weird
per i didn't i didn't go to the weird
people
i didn't go you know i didn't go to the
predators or whatever right just
i i just noticed that they were all just
wanting to help wanting to give great
advice or opinions
that's really what it was for me that's
great and so
after six or seven year or eight you
were like i think i'm good yeah whatever
it was
i don't need to it got yeah it got to
the point where i was getting so many
varied opinions that were so different
from each other because this person
would say
fix this and that person would say no
keep that fix this so it was
very very different i got to the point
where i was like okay
i've got enough i can choose from if i
want to
and then honestly what ended up
happening was i picked
a couple here and there and um
then very bluntly to myself said what do
you need to fix
rip your emotions out step on your heart
be a businessman now
you've already done the art part be a
businessman what needs to be fixed
and then i had to read it you know
i gave myself months before i reread it
i read it
i re-read it and said okay there's not
enough of this
so we got to put that in or this is
leaning way too much over here let's cut
that
and then i just started cutting it and
um
and and adding in the very little bits
that i got from all the notes like
that i did like that and i would just
put them in here and there if i needed
to
but i got to the point where it was the
most important point i think any artist
can get to is
self-evaluation you know and just saying
you know what this needs to go
or this needs to stay or i need to
adjust that and being able to just step
away from it emotionally
and logically say i need to fix this
because
that's the best piece of advice i can
give is learn to step away from your ego
and learn to learn to cut when you have
to
you know don't be precious about your
work i like that
i think that's easy for everybody to do
i don't know it was
it sounds very hard it's easier said
than done i think
um it it it got to the point was like
it's like breaking up honestly it you
it's really hard at first
but suddenly you see a whole new world
you know it's like oh
i didn't die from this i'm okay i and
then it just got exciting then i just
got
i developed and then i developed the
habit of cutting
i developed a habit of self editing
right so
and then you get more seasoned with your
writing and you get more proficient and
then you get to the point where it's
like no it's just part of the job
you know and so then you start now i
look forward to it and then in the
editing room i was like okay what else
can we cut what else can we cut what
else can we cut you know my editor was
like well if you keep cutting you're not
gonna have a movie
i was like he's like getting so good at
this he goes trust me
you get to point you get from point a to
point b as fast you could they say you
know enter a scene as fast as possible
get out of it as fast as possible
and he goes you're doing that fine
you're good don't worry about cutting
any more than you
you need to so that was the next piece
of advice i had to learn was don't over
cut just because it got easy to cut you
know
or don't over self-edit because it's it
got easy to
so learn how to self-edit and then
know when to edit you know
was there a certain structure you used
or guidelines that you followed
yeah the the basics the basic story arc
structure you know
first first introduction of the world by
page 10 11 there's an inciting incident
um
that kind of offers the character a new
look at life
in my film it's a mcguffin it's a
physical object it's a cell phone
um by page 25-ish you know he's made the
choice
to enter into this new journey this new
world and
by the midpoint of the film a big
something happens
and you know he gets to a point where he
is at the point of no return or he's
gonna make this
decision to go into this new way of life
or not and
you know it when you when a character
does that it's they're either
a hero or they're like the hero's
journey or the tragic hero's journey and
um at that point of no return and then
by
you know the last 15 minutes that 15
pages of the film you're entering back
into the new the old world forever
changed i mean it's classic formula it's
classic storytelling arc
you know three three act structure um
with
uh a midpoint and the the beat breakups
in between each act
yeah it's classic and it works so do it
so you really you down to the page 100
to the page
it makes everything easy it's color by
number at that point it's got 90 pages
90 minutes first 10 pages establish the
world
you know establish your character who
your character is by action
what is he doing that tells the audience
who they or he or she
what are they doing that tells the
audience who they are that'll then let
the audience know
who they have to become right and then
and then
okay for the next 10 pages i have to
kind of
rustle some things up so that this
character learns something
all right now we're into act two okay
well act two i'm gonna throw some
curveballs at him
all right we get to the midpoint all
right let's let's have something big
happen
right and then you go from there and
it's you're just plugging
ideas into these spaces and it makes
writing so much easier
for me now there's a lot of debate yeah
a lot of debates so it sounds like it
worked for you and that's me
and it'll forever work for me that way
it's good to know
what did you love about the story that
kept you writing or were there days
where you're like you know what i'm
bored with this i need to change this
around
um it was it was just the progression
of the story it was honestly the
progression of finishing something
finishing a feature
that was super motivating um as far as
the story i i hadn't i knew
where the character was going to end up
so i just knew i had to get there
um and it was just uh i
in my treatment i had it broken a beat
by beat in 12 pages right so basically
page 1 of the treatment was the first 10
pages of the film
page 2 of the treatment was the next 10
and just checking those off crossing
them out with a red marker
every that was just awesome i was like
okay i got
18 more beats to go i got 17 more 16
more and then
um so it was more logical the story was
already set in my mind it wasn't like i
was
writing to explore something it was just
finishing it that was exciting for me
once you were finished did you start
sending it out to producers
how did all that work um
i knew i was just going to make it so i
sent it out to producers
who were i always say students of film
rather than film students
i think there's this difference i think
we're all students of film um
but i i set out for i sent it to a
couple
very independent producers who really
know and i think
they're trying to get their start too i
said are you interested in making a
feature film
because if you are i have one it's gonna
take a lot of work but i have one
that you can get under your belt because
i knew where i was at this is the first
feature for me i knew i wasn't gonna
you know get a major major player in the
game yet um
and i wanted to find someone who was at
my level so that they could have
something on their belt too
um and a lot of them said i'm totally
interested and then i never heard back
from them
oh gosh yeah until i
decided fine i'm going to produce it and
um i started doing all the things that a
producer would do
you know i started um
finding locations and finding
other team members to build it and
started hunting for a whole team and
found a team who then connected us to
the producer of the film
and um she is my rock she will be my
producer forever she's amazing her name
is kristen direnna oh she's nice she's
great at what she does
yeah and how important was that that you
two clicked because it sounds like you
guys are
you have almost a friendship and yeah it
sounds like it's very very important
super important i think um again
one side of my logical brain says it's
just business
so it doesn't you don't have to click
with a person but just get the business
done
but it's so much more fun and works way
better when you do click when you're
friends and you're going to work with
people you love and
and you're saying yeah let's let's throw
ideas back and forth
most importantly you have to be that
friend too you know being the director
or whatever you have to be that person
that you expect them to be
you have to treat them the way they want
you want them to treat you you know
you have to be open for their ideas and
and say yes and say no and
debate and figure things out but yeah
absolutely
super important to be friends with them
i i think it's more fun that way
you know it's way more fun well also too
there's going to be things that will go
wrong in production and it'll be
you'll be there like you know having
people you'd be 11 hour you know
yeah just stressed out and then totally
to have it be smooth
i would call her and say i need him i
need to emotionally vent
you know that's what it was me coming
can i have her number
yes absolutely she would love it okay
but it got to that point where i was
like i'm just gonna
give you all my baggage and the the
production baggage and the emotional
baggage and
everything and she graciously took it
and just manned it and
handed it handled business and she did
such a great job because i got to the
point where i
was struggling i had two producers on
the film actually and
the other one said maggie again going to
her and saying
um i need you to get this done now she
would just do it
they were very very good at that and
because i respected them and loved them
as people
it made it so much easier yeah that's
awesome
but if you don't if you don't have
someone you totally agree with just
remember that it is
a business and you can work with people
you don't like
to achieve a goal as long as you all can
keep your egos in check you may not like
each other fine
but remember you're going to work to
tell a story to make a movie
and that's more important than anything
else
well a scenario that was brought up in a
comment over the weekend
was great and forgive me i don't have
their youtube
um name here but i can put a screenshot
in the video and they just brought up
the fact that be
aware that sometimes if the director has
not enough of their own sort of camp not
enough their own friends or allies on
set
that the production could be kind of
almost like steered away from them and i
thought that was a really interesting
point
i've never experienced that i've never
directed a a film
like that um but i was just wondering
what your thoughts are yeah i've yet to
be on a big big major production
um where there's lots and lots of hands
involved
um so i i don't know if i can speak to
that yet because
i just know from the experience i've had
i i'm sure that does happen for sure uh
i i hope it happens less i hope people
are more collaborative
than than they're not i hope people are
like yeah let's all work together to
make this happen and that's the dream
obviously
um but i'm sure that does happen and i
wouldn't i don't know not been in that
experience yet so i don't know how to
speak to it you know how to
give advice appropriately how to handle
a situation like that
because yeah i guess he was just saying
that you know just make sure that you
have some of your own people
it's almost like a ceo being ousted from
their company there's too many board
members or shareholders whatever say
you know what let's get rid of them and
they have their own idea and so and that
has happened
um where people have these agendas and
so
take it boil it down to an indie film
set and
you're trying to make your day yeah
you're you're you want to get people to
lunch or dinner whatever and if they're
stressed
and then you have these other agendas
around and
i was really intrigued by that yeah well
i guess i'll say this be
like i read this quote the other day i
forget who said it but be so good they
can't get rid of you i feel like you
said it but yeah
it'd be so good they can't you know um
and and be so
be so fun and happy that they don't want
to
that is true that is true you know i but
i don't know
that's a scary situation i would i don't
like thinking about it because it just
seems so not fun
yeah but i i think well i i guess life
isn't always like
i'm happy and i don't know what i say
today it doesn't happen i i just hope
that it doesn't
you know sure sure and i agree with what
you're saying and i think that's great
when you're
with people that you've met that you
mesh with yeah and that you know
okay they trust you you trust them yes
maybe i'll say this
as a young filmmaker establish your
tribe early
ooh okay establish your tribe early like
these like the people i worked with on
this film they will always
be the first to have the option to shoot
this or not you know if they're busy on
another project we'll find someone else
but they'll always get it first because
they're amazing people and i know the
system and i
truly think that financiers
don't want to lose money right and so if
they
can hire a team that does mesh
all the better you know because they
want to avoid those pitfalls they want
to avoid losing money on a project
because the crew wasn't getting along
so if establish your tribe early say i
have a producer i have a writer i have
actors i have
i have this i have these people if you
want to look at others
fine you know we can talk but just know
that you'll get a great quality project
from this team so work now to establish
your tribe
so that you don't get ousted later and
if and if you're a director for hire
or whatever and they bring you a board
um
you know earn your stripes earn your
place and say you know this
be so be such a great person they don't
want to get rid of you sure you know
because that's
that was scary yeah it was it was not so
much getting rid of it was um
taking a group sort of by consensus
taking
the production over and steering it in a
certain way because
there were too many people in the same
camp that had the same agenda i think
that's what this comment was
and i was like wow that is really
interesting i mean you hear about famous
ceos that
same thing happened right right two and
yeah and honestly the only thing i could
i can put myself in that position in my
imagination and at that point i would i
would look at my
myself if the the masses are saying
we're gonna we're gonna take control
then there might be something that i'm
doing i would look at my i would look at
myself and say
maybe maybe i need to look at this
differently um
yeah so david just brought up something
great
behind the camera that be careful who
your dp is
because that's really where they could
also steer away yeah i can totally see
that i i was looking
i i uh i had two i was looking at for
this film
um the one i eventually hired and then
this older gentleman
um he had a lot of experience been
around for a long time but in my gut
because i told him hey we're going to be
working with a lot of young people and
um he goes i have a lot of ideas and i
go that's great i i
welcome the ideas and he goes i don't
know if i would like to work with
an assistant dp because um i just don't
know if
you know he might have an idea that i
don't agree with and vice versa and it
seemed like he had experiences where
his ideas were not welcomed or something
um
and i just knew in that moment that he
was not going to be easy to work with
because
he had already simply told me in the
interview process that
he wasn't sure about welcoming other
ideas
you know and i knew that i
didn't want to deal with that you know
and i don't know if it was a
generational thing you know he wasn't
i don't mind working with people who are
experienced for sure
but he was very sure that he
was going to have his ideas and if they
weren't agreed with that was fine
but his ideas you know he trusted and
i'm way more collaborative than that you
know so
i went with a dp who was just at a usc
young guy amazing i loved him
he was great his name's isaac park and
he's just an awesome dude
and gave so much always come to me what
do you want this to feel like
and that's my language okay well i
wanted to feel like this he said i got
it
i did not even look at the dailies i
trusted his eye that much
i just said i trust you because we had
that relationship
you know and i i wouldn't have gotten
that from the other guy
for sure i think i saw that he was the
co-direct like so you had two directing
credits
you were a director no well okay so i i
directed under pseudonym
oh yeah okay it's out now
because i i didn't want
i didn't want the focus to be the
directing i wanted my i did this so that
i could be an actor
and a writer and i felt it'd be safer to
direct under pseudonym because
uh they would take less attention off
the focus they take less focus off on
the directing and put more focus on
the acting which is what i really want
to do and write
i will do i will direct i love it
but it's not it wasn't my focus so
that's why i directed under pseudonym
yeah i'm not even credited as the
director oh okay yeah
and um it's like the kaiser so say yeah
right yeah
uh so then with isaac so i'm sure he's
definitely directing when you're in a
scene
because that would be difficult he he he
he didn't um he would call action um
okay we'd split up on who called cut
um he would direct he would direct the
frame
the framing for sure i need you guys to
stay in frame this way or this is the
framing you have or this is your
this is what you've got but as far as
like the character work and directing
the story
he left that all up to me wow really
gracious like that
he just wanted to make the film look
beautiful and
that's i cared about that i'll tell the
good story you make it look pretty
and because i can write literary
metaphor all day
but translating literary metaphor into
visuals
not necessarily my forte so i needed
someone i could trust
who could see my ideas and
make that a visual actuality and he was
great with that
how did you set the budget for the film
great um a little little nervous to talk
about this because
i will but it's it's because i want
people to take it seriously and i don't
want them to look at it
look at the money um because we didn't
have a lot
um and i want them to say you know what
who cares that it was shot for this
that's a good story
we had four thousand dollars production
budget period that's all we had was four
thousand dollars and
cliche i called all my aunts and my
uncles my dad my family
friends with the family and said hey i
can shoot this for a thousand dollars i
need 200 bucks from each of you
and they all chipped in they were all
really excited because they know and i
ended up with four thousand dollars and
i told everyone this is what we have to
make this film
so let's do it and i will say very up
front it was so much easier to do than
people think
yeah and why do you think that you were
able to get it under the wire like that
like under the four thousand dollar mark
it's a feature right feature
everyone first and foremost um
everyone did it because for the credit
they everyone i hired them on the said
listen
this is what i got we can make it look
really good we can get locations we can
get i'll feed you guys every day
but unfortunately right now um we're
gonna have to
the the eyeballs that people put on this
film
the the credit of having a feature under
your belt that's
our payment that's everyone's payment
right now that's my payment i'm not
ashamed to say that
as a new young indie filmmaker i'm not
ashamed to say that because we all start
there we all have
you know um i i had what i had and
that's what we could
go with um and and so they were all just
so gung-ho
about it they were all said you know
what the story is worth it it's a great
enough story
to make it happen so yeah they were
willing to put all their effort their
time their life they gave me 23 days of
their life
straight wow yeah 23 days straight no
breaks
and we shot the whole thing in that time
for that amount of money and it's
so doable um but it again going back to
having a great solid team
yeah it worked there was one occasion
where i had to
kind of as the director say i had to
pull someone aside and say listen
this this behavior is it didn't work
it's not working
let's correct it and they graciously
took it and said
you're right i'm sorry i was stressed
because of the time limit and the time
crunch
and it's never i go there's always going
to be time limits there's always going
to be stresses there's always going to
be money issues there's always going to
be that
get used to that now in a place you can
and and take that with you
and this person graciously accepted the
advice and we just progressed on
um but but yeah
i literally asking every family member i
had
if they could help fund it and they did
and we made it work
that's awesome they believe in you and
they want to see you happy and do well
always have yeah that's very cool yeah
and i don't
think i wanted to say that i don't think
that that should be out of the norm
you know i want i want great experiences
like this to be the norm i i feel like
there's this general
feeling about bleeding for the art and
you know van gogh cutting off your ear
to make great art it's like
i never i want to make movies it's so
much fun right i want to make them with
great people
and and i understand that there's lots
of stresses and i think
you know i think that's what kind of
leads to a lot of the problems is a
person people not being able to handle
their own stresses
um but if you can set your ego aside and
just have a great time making movies
with people then that holds that's the
reason we were able to do it with four
thousand dollars because
everyone involved was just excited and
happy to do it
now that doesn't take into account post
right no okay so that was
so production post production we had
zero
zero dollars because i had four thousand
period
so again i i reached out to a lot of
young
people who were trying to develop
credits for themselves sound engineers
sound mixers composers
and i said hey you want to be credited
on a feature this is what i can offer
later
this is what we're doing that all of
them again number one we'll ask first
right and i just asked that hey would
you want to be a part of this every one
of them said yes
every one of them i would get responses
like crazy i was never trying to take
advantage of anybody
um but i knew i had a feature and that
that magical word is amazing
right and um you know in the post i
would let people like our editor for
example i said hey
my editor was doing a lot of industrials
and he was really looking to get into
narrative work
and i said i have a feature and he said
okay let's do it and he gave so much
six months of his time to edit the whole
thing oh wow i mean and turn around was
amazing
taking notes so graciously um i would
always ask what do you think
you know being collaborative and it was
just an amazing experience my editor's
matt ron
amazing guy amazing guy um
and then yeah with like the composers i
i had one composer who felt really
overburdened by all the music we had
it's all latin themed music
very very high energetic and i said hey
would you mind if i got a bunch of other
guys to work and they said yeah
so i would reached out to a bunch of
composers and said hey can you do a cut
two songs
all yes totally 100 yes i said this is
the deal we don't have this or that and
i said totally fine i can i can manage
two songs
and they all they all just jumped on
board and it was just amazing
amazing um you know some some of the
songs i had to cut some of the songs i
used whatever but
it was really an exciting experience to
just bring a bunch of people in
because they wanted to be a part of a
feature you know
do you think if it had been a short it
would have been different just because
with the future okay yeah i think so um
features is it's just a calling card
it's a huge calling card when you are
credited to a future um i keep saying
that word but i
can't stress it enough it's a it's a big
word in this industry it is yeah
when you have a feature to do or being
done or working working on people want
to be a part of that
especially if it's the first time for
them um
and and they've been in the industry for
some time and they just haven't had
their break yet and
and they've been doing industrials or
they've been doing music videos or
commercials for a long time like they're
ready to take tackle something bigger
they they are just ask you never know
who you're gonna meet you never know who
you're gonna be a part of and
ninety percent of the time they'll reach
out and say yeah i'm totally willing to
help you know
and i'm so grateful for them they they
they know it i've told them hundreds
hundreds of times how grateful i am for
them because they made the film
they made it you know i had the idea i
orchestrated it but
without them wouldn't be a film and did
you screen it for all of them
oh yeah and how was that uh it was
exciting to first and foremost it was
exciting to have the crew and cast see
it because
um it was their sweat and blood that
went into it um
but then having random people there also
friends families
you know who could then validate their
work
validate what we had done and say yeah
it was great or it was good or i loved
it was watchable
which is what i wanted more than
anything just have a watchable film
someone
something people could watch on a friday
night you know and to see
their reactions like oh my gosh like it
happened
it it it like i think a lot of people in
la
they talk a lot more than they act and
i've met a lot of them and
we're gonna get a feature done this and
that and the fact that it got done and
they saw that it got done they were like
whoa this like happened
and then to have people watch it was
crazy for them i think
it's amazing that's really cool yeah how
do you find these young eager
creatives that will work on a feature
film okay um
so i went to a site called mandy.com
i went to craigslist and i posted an ad
with very transparent instructions
this is what we're doing this is what i
have
this is what i can offer you very
transparent as honest as possible
and the people who are okay with that
emailed
and if they weren't okay with that then
they didn't email right
i got a ton of emails so many hours
after i posted
i'd love to be a part of it i'd love to
read the feature i'd love to to help
with the music i'd love to do this or
that
um and mandy.com was a great resource
craigslist was a great resource of
course i vetted a lot of them
for sure um but i found that
when i and again when i said students of
film then everyone came in i wanted
people
because i mean my dp was two or three
years out of usc
you know and really was ready for
something big um
so they all just were willing to to work
and it was
using those resources reaching out on
that site and being as transparent as
possible
right that's the key because they all
knew what they were getting into
there was no secrets there was no like
oh we're out of money or we have more
money than no they knew
they knew there was 4 000 bucks they
knew what they were getting into
and that was that and they will if you
build it they will come
right they will reach out to you if
they're interested and if they're not
they won't don't worry about them
describe to be transparent like how how
is because i've seen some stuff on
craigslist it's like
blunt all caps seven explanation points
and you're like whoa
right okay maybe two letting people know
what they're getting in for so
i have a feature film we are shooting it
for 20 days
straight no breaks we have four thousand
dollars that four thousand dollars is
going to locations
it's going to equipment and it's going
to feeding you um
we're shooting all over la um and
this is how we're this is how we're
gonna shoot it it's an indie drama
um and this is what you can expect right
um this is who i am as a person and when
you're that transparent with the facts
you know you're not saying well we have
some investors looking you know
we have potentially twenty thousand
dollars coming no don't be ashamed that
you have no money don't be ashamed of
that
all right just let them know straight up
this is how it is you don't have to
break it down their door with it there's
gonna be all caps
don't oversell it don't be super excited
oh my gosh we're doing it you know
just be be calm be relaxed
have fun we're making a feature film
let's have some fun
and and it's going to be a lot of hard
work
but if you're in for that then then
you're welcome
and i got so many likes i've got so many
interviews and i just picked the ones i
wanted
so it sounds like you were open and fair
and honest instead of like
trying to pull the wool over someone on
someone's eyes or like
being so like blunt and mean about it
that people like scares people away
i was never trying to be more than i was
i think a lot of people i i've met
are like oh i've got this in the
pipeline or i've got that in the
pipeline i'm doing this or
i'm working i look them up two seconds
later and they're they're
no well you know i was a child actor and
i'm working on this now and then it's
like they have like maybe
half of credit or whatever i was i was
very blunt but this is the first time
feature
from a person who has never directed a
film before if you're interested
welcome yeah so that's great be open
like that i like that
isn't it kind of crazy though that you
had a short or a couple shorts that
you've done
and then here you've taken this big leap
where
you're writing directing or co-directing
producing um and then
you're the protagonist right in a
feature like how how does that happen
bold that that's scary yeah it was it
again i
i shot the film when i was 30 right so
it took a long time to get to that point
it wasn't overnight
you know i had bit i had done a lot of
short films my whole life growing up
with my friends
family in college done a lot of training
as an actor
i really learned how to write well took
a year and a half
studying videos from great youtube
channels
on how to tell good story through film
how to direct how to direct a film how
to light how to
learning what cameras are and and you
know f-stops and all this stuff i took a
year and a half to learn all that
um because i didn't go to film school
right that youtube was my film school
you guys were part of my film school
right
so um it it
it wasn't crazy because it was the right
time it was
it was i was ready for it um it would
have been crazy having to try this when
i was 22.
that went crazy but um
it was just i was just ready for it you
know i i was done with shorts i was done
with five
five minute shorts i was done with 15
minutes short i was just ready to make a
big one
and um and like i said it just all fell
into place
it really did it was i wasn't scared i
wasn't nervous i was excited
you know looking back in hindsight
you know having finished the feature and
writing the words the end
that was an amazing experience amazing
feeling but
um be just just
don't run before you can walk and take
the time to prepare yourself and
practice
you know i i was very strict growing up
when i was writing my shorts and doing
my shorts
i was writing five page shorts and i was
writing
i was practicing how to write a full
story arc of five pages
religiously sticking to five pages
giving myself a five page budget
and then advancing okay now i'm gonna do
10 pages
and that was that and i never did
anything more than that but i got really
used to writing to a page budget so when
i had to write 90 pages
i got it to 90 pages you know
so like i said it wasn't crazy because i
was prepared i i watched a movie
last year documentary uh free solo and
in an interview with alex holland he
he said they were asking how much
adrenaline are you feeling up there and
he goes well i wasn't feeling any
adrenaline
adrenaline is when things go wrong i was
calm i was collected i was ready for
this
this experience and i totally agree with
that i had i felt nervous or
unprepared then i think it would have
been crazy but i was ready
i was ready for it so you finished the
film
you finished editing and then
now you have this movie what what are
you doing with it okay
so it's it it's never as easy as
it's not as easy as i thought it was
going to be as far as okay the editing's
done it's done
because we shot on a professional cinema
camera right so there's a lot that goes
into editing
raw footage right so then it's like okay
time to color the film
can i learn how to color a film so i did
um
need to learn how to uh compose
music i can't do that so i gotta find
people who can so it
it took a long time to it took about a
year a year to
finish the film um at that point when
it's all completed
uh we we talked to my producer and we'd
say how are we gonna distribute this
thing how are we gonna get people's
eyeballs on it
right um obviously the most popular
route is the film festival route which i
was
never interested in actually um i
i talked to all my my team before and i
said hey we're just probably going to go
vod
just leave it at that i'm not really
interested in festivals they said that's
fine
um but then i decided that
festivals offer eyeballs people to see
so we submitted to
lots of festivals uh and we are
continuing to submit to loss of
festivals
now that it's fully completed and still
having to get to hear back from things
uh we recently got into the new
filmmakers festival here now
great um that's very exciting so we we
they
every month they premiere a feature and
then a bunch of shorts and we are the
feature for next month
just super exciting uh so yeah june 29th
and we're really excited about that nice
um which where is it located down
downtown la
i think it's called the south park
center in downtown l.a
um and uh they host film they host film
festival every month
it's so cool because it's we're not the
way a year right for something cool um
it's all new new budding filmmakers um
people who are just getting their start
in the industry it's
awesome so it's a really good resource a
really good film festival to look into
for young
young new filmmakers um
but again submitting to all the big
festivals i never was hoping for
distribution
through those festivals i was just
hoping for people to see the film
um but mostly vod um
amazon prime is amazing because amazon
video direct
as long as you have the right technical
specs for your camera for your film
uh the right closed captions and um
two pieces of art you can upload through
video direct and then you can have your
video on amazon prime tomorrow
and then it's all about you know the
promotions which is crazy
so um after after we see how these
festivals kind of run
um if we get into them or not then we'll
just go straight back to amazon prime
and we're in the talks currently with
um one of the pr individual an
individual with pr
for netflix and she's kind of helping us
develop our press packets and everything
for that so we can develop buzz around
it
and then we're gonna set up you know
press screenings and try to just get as
many eyeballs on the phone as possible
but it is definitely self-distributing
for sure
do you know what the specs are for a
video direct yeah so
um closed captions are absolute must
i would say follow netflix's standard
for
for closed captions netflix has a really
specific standard amazon doesn't have
a specific standard but if you follow
netflix's standard it kind of covers
the across the board everyone um
all the vod sites i think they have the
best standard uh you can look it up
online it's right there
um that's what we did we followed their
standards to a t i mean it's
as specific as um no less your your
caption can't be less than 20 20 frames
um you have to have a minimum of two
frames separating each caption
oh wow um you can't don't separate your
your
phrases at adjectives or things like
that it's very specific
but just follow those guidelines um and
then
you'll be really good amazon will take
them um two pieces of art
uh you have to have your a poster and
then
um another poster that in different
sizes they have their i'm not familiar
with the sizes right now but they have
their sizes on their site
um build those posters really easy
upload the two pieces of art
and then you'll have those set to go and
then upload your film
and your film i i don't think i think
they've gotten tighter
recently i can't speak for amazon
specifically but
um because i knew we shot on a cinema
camera with all professional sound and
everything i knew we would be okay
i i think back in the past they would
like just allow home video kind of stuff
i don't know if they do
anymore um but they will review it and
then
within four two to four business days
it'll be up live on amazon prime
and you have a film on amazon prime for
everyone to see right now
and then i think that's really really
solid because then you can use that
you know hey hulu we're talking to we
run amazon prime you can check it out
right now
netflix run amazon prime you can check
it out right now most importantly press
hey you can check out our our film on
amazon prime right now
um and it's got some clout amazon's got
clout and they have an oscar
they have an officer so yeah so it's a
really really great place to
host your film in the beginning while
you're still trying to generate buzz
i know you have submitted to a few
festivals but
you said in the beginning you didn't
really want to go that route
uh i i felt like festivals had a stigma
attached i felt like
it was the only thing indie filmmakers
could do is go to festivals and i felt
like there was a lot of
pressure a lot of pressure to get your
film seen at
a festival and find distribution to sell
it and
it was really stressful just thinking
about that i just wanted people to watch
it
right i wasn't concerned with selling
the film i wanted people just to watch
it
so i opted out of the festivals because
i just thought it was gonna be way too
much pressure for our team
uh we did more research and realized
that festivals are really
are an avenue it's not the avenue that i
think a lot of
young filmmakers think but it is an
avenue when we looked at it like that
then it was like oh yeah let's let's
just
submit we might as well you know i know
that a lot of festivals
um when you're invited you're guaranteed
in and some festivals you're just paying
for the
hotel rooms i get that um but there's a
lot of these small
local festivals you know you may not get
a big
distribution deal there but you will get
people seeing it
and that's exciting and word of mouth
spreads
so yeah we didn't want to because we
just i just thought that it was
way too much pressure having done the
research i realized that it's just a
really
another great avenue so now we're
submitting
very interesting so you change because a
lot of times it seems like people want
to do the festival route and then
something happens and they change their
mind so it sounds like you know i
actually
i didn't want to do it at all yeah do
you think one of the caveats will be
that you have to go
you want it to be where at least you can
attend because you know it's a different
feeling when you're right when you're
there
i i would find a way there no matter
what no matter where it was
um i that wasn't an issue
um because if my film was there i was
gonna be there um
i think it was just just the pressure of
a lot of young people
trying the trying desperately to make a
sale
and that just seemed like it was no fun
you know
like if you go to festivals like i'm
sure we've all been to
you're just there to watch great art you
know and i think we need to remember
that
it's i i i didn't i didn't i was just i
just didn't want to worry about
selling the film sure well there's afm
which is fantastic yeah
i mean that's a whole nother whole
different volume yeah right right
yeah the film market is like you that's
awesome an awesome opportunity too you
know because everyone's there to buy and
sell everything
and you go into that knowing that
right like that's something i i prepare
my mind
for right i'm gonna if i go to afm i'm
going there with
the the mentality to work deals
right for sure yeah there you go and
that's what you should do at the afm
i think festivals people i think people
sometimes forget that festivals are film
festivals and they try to treat film
festivals as afm
right i think they forget that it's like
okay maybe maybe there'll be a big
producer here will see my film and buy
it
so we'll just go to afm right sure you
know but
if you're gonna go to a film festival
just be happy with people watching it
you know did you get to do q and a's or
we
yes we are we are going to because this
is our world premiere at this festival
it's our world premieres that's the
first one i thought sorry i thought you
already screened it nothing else
we screened it out it was a private
premiere for my friends and family
that kind of thing we did a q a there um
but this one the this one does
the new filmmakers festival it has a q a
that we're very excited about i don't
know what
in store for that it's very a really
relaxed q a we just chat
it's really what it is i've been to the
new filmmakers festival and
it's awesome awesome q a and they have a
red carpet
yeah they have a little red carpet they
have a stefan repeat so you're taking
pictures
and the outfit ready and they have they
have like a party for it's just super
awesome yeah it's super awesome it's an
event yeah it's an event they
really really take care of to try and
make
as many people come to this thing as
possible they are here for new
filmmakers
it is an amazing festival and we are so
grateful to be a part
of it they have themed months like next
month is lgbtq because it's pride month
and
so ours is because it deals with a young
gay man it's being featured there and
for that for that um that genre and
so yeah i don't know what to expect as
far as the q a i'm very excited though
yeah i've heard about people even for
shorts like driving from other states
just so they can go to that red carpet
because it's
it makes you feel like you know this it
happened i know that's such a small part
of it but it's so fun it's kind of a
cool reminder of like
okay we did this i know that that this
is not why we do it but
this is sort of like that the the cherry
on top the icing on the cake
it's exciting because after that you
know um movie maker magazine
interviews the filmmaker so that's
really exciting as well
i love that magazine very cool super
great that publication's awesome
um so yeah it's just a whole really
amazing event that
these guys host and so this is the world
premiere and then from there we'll see
what other festivals we can get into
i know a lot of festivals have world
premiere caveats so
they want to own the world premiere
status um i know big ones like hands and
sundance and south by southwest all
these big
ones want the world premiere so that's
okay
if we don't get into those that's fine
um
we we're just excited to be at any of
the festivals
at this point you know and pride is june
i
i don't want to say i don't really know
i'm assuming so because
next year next month's festival is all
lgbtq
okay themed films yeah so then maybe you
could submit
i mean do you do you only want it to be
seen in that genre or it sounds like
it's it's
it's just a it's a film about
relationships it's a film about it's a
film of
growing up in your 20s oh it's a film
about learning who you are in the 20s
he doesn't he doesn't question his
sexuality he's a gay he's a young gay
man but
so many people are who cares right he's
just a young gay man um
it's really about growing up in your 20s
which i think is is important i think
it's just remembering that everyone's a
human and everyone grows up in your 20s
and everyone figures things out messes
up
regardless of race orientation he just
happens to be a young gay man who's
dealing with certain things
like growing up right interesting yeah
so
any festival can take it you know um
i wasn't trying to set out writing a
a film that had a specific message about
whatever i just wanted to write a film
about people growing up
you know did when you did the friends
and family
um screening i realize everybody's kind
of close to everybody
that's there but what were some of the
questions was it about orientation
or was it just about life i mean do they
have to they i think i think they read
it well
as it was just a film about life um
actually surprising a lot of questions
were about the music oh
yeah because it's all latin themed music
there's a lot of mambo
and salsa and conga drums and and they
were like where did you come up with
that idea and it was like i
i just knew that he needed a a
a rhythmic sound that pulled him towards
something and latin music was perfect
for that
um but yeah no nothing nothing
specifically about race or anything like
or
orientation or anything like that they
just knew that it was just a story about
a young person
growing up he happens to be gay right
you know
is there anything you wish you'd had
someone tell you before you made
the feature was there something here and
there where if someone could just have
warned you
everything i wished i would have known i
i learned i learned from
channels like yours and other youtube
channels um where i learned how to i
mean i'm
youtube was my film school no joke um in
fact there are so i mean there's so many
channels
in thank you in my credits you guys are
in the thank you on my credit
really you guys taught me so much right
thank you so
so everything i wished i had learned i i
made sure to learn
right um any of the pitfalls or the
warnings i got all that
in my studies okay what can i look out
for
what can i so i learned from everyone's
mistakes and i think that's why it was
such an enjoyable easy smooth experience
for us um
if i really think hard about something i
wish i could have learned um i
i think the one thing i will say is i
wish i there was more focus on b-roll
for sure it's such a weird detail but i
wish i had learned
to shoot b-roll and plan for b-roll and
inserts
and stuff well before him because when
we got to our post
editing i had nothing i had no b-roll i
had to reshoot a bunch of stuff and it
just none of it makes sense
right inserts come on right um so
that that's one interesting detail i
wish i had really learned about
beforehand was planning for b-roll
um because we didn't and we didn't know
when we didn't have any and we had to
reshoot a ton of stuff it was tough
um but as far as like the experience of
filmmaking no i
i heard the lessons and i took them from
all the channels i watched and whatnot
so yeah there was nothing i looked back
like oh man i wish i didn't do this
no i i just followed the guidelines that
people talked talk
yeah what about set photography did you
have a lot i wish we had i wish we did
um you had a few though yeah on your
facebook yes
uh we had the producers taking candid
shots
um i didn't instruct them to thank god
they did
um but having a set photography is
super necessary because uh they're one
they're capturing the moment
capturing the excitement the memories
but it's so great for publicity
so great behind the scenes is so much
fun to study and look and research and
learn about so our producers did take
some
um but uh it's not some i wish we would
have had an on
cent photographer all the time but
couldn't get one
yeah yeah um
and i wasn't worried about spoilers
either because we're
we're not known so spoil the crap out of
it right
get people to know what this is oh
there's a new film what's this mean
what's that mean great talk about it
i mean we're not like we're not like a
major major blockbuster who needs to
keep everything tight-lipped no i want
to find out yeah take pictures leak
whatever you can i want people to find
out about this thing you know
i remember when la la land i think was
like leaked right oh right
right now there was like some pictures
far away and now you're finding
now you're finding directors like well
if we're gonna have paparazzi leak it i
might as well leak it myself
sure so at least let's get the pictures
to look good right let's get the videos
to look good
and uh yeah it's like it's like part of
the game now i think you know leaking
your stuff
to hype it up but yeah i had people
leaked my stuff i would have felt
honored
you know because no one knows about it
yet so
so when do you think it'll be out i know
you said it's up on amazon prime is it
for
use for purchase well it's currently not
on amazon prime
at this moment anymore because the film
um
the the film festival wants the world
once the world release so we
it was literally on for eight hours we
got the email saying we were in
we took it right down eight hours so it
wasn't like well
we didn't really break any rules because
like no one saw it really it was like
eight hours live
um so it will be live on amazon prime
july
1st july 1st which is like two days
after the festival
um and then yeah it'll be live there
anyone can watch it you know
but for now we need to give the priority
to the festival understandable
you know everyone has their their
regulations and their
statuses that they need to hit so yeah
so you're going to try to find
distribution netflix whatever and if
for whatever reason that doesn't happen
are you going to do an aggregator where
you're going to then put it on video i i
thought about going through distributor
um uh they're
obviously the go-to i know distributor
works directly with netflix
netflix
dollars i don't have the funds for them
unfortunately um
but they're they're amazing so knowing
knowing the small connections i have
that's kind of the route we're going um
so like again amazon prime anyone can
get on we're
we will be on a january july 1st um
and uh and then from there it's about
promoting it
uh you know getting a budget for
promotions um
and then the connections we have um i
still do a lot more research on any
other aggregation
any other services like that because i
totally think they're just
super helpful and amazing for indie
filmmakers they have doors that
sometimes we can't get into and they're
already in
and they know how to vet your film they
know to make sure everything's tight
and up to standard right i have to learn
that without them
because i don't have the money for it so
um i would love to
i would love to go through them but or
other other distribution aggregation
stuff but
at this point we're just doing it
ourselves did you learn any lessons
about directing actors that would be
helpful for other
first-time directors yeah fortunately
being an actor first i knew how i liked
being directed
so i was able to translate that to my
actors
[Music]
number one is story is first
for anyone actors or exerciser story is
first
that's the most important thing um and
when when you are directing actors
um actors are smart people
we're emotionally smart right so speak
to them in a way that is
prodding ideas or inviting ideas versus
telling them
exactly what to do how to say a line
you don't want to give anyone a line
reading because you're the director
you're not the actor you want to say you
know stuff like okay so this is what the
character
is feeling at this moment because um
because of
this moment earlier right what do you
think
what do you think he's feeling and
you're in your perspective and then you
start to talk back and forth you sort of
use a spitball um and then you kind of
come to a consensus
if you see a take for example in my film
we had a moment
um where our main act one of our actors
uh his name is michael king he plays
the character ted he it's it's the
climax of the film is a very emotional
moment
my character is crying and he's trying
to console the character he starts
crying and it's a lot of emotions and
cry and tears and i look at him i say
hey
your character wouldn't be crying right
now all right your character has has
completed his arc he's strong
he's he's he's he's um no longer this uh
individual who who's gonna be he'll be
vulnerable with him but you're his rock
right and and i gave him that kind of
direction it was more metaphorical
and he said got it and then he was able
to change his delivery
right i didn't tell him how to deliver
it i told him what the emotions behind
the delivery were and he interpreted
that
so i think in in to make a longer story
short
is really think about the the emotions
speak to an actor emotionally metaphors
get them to understand
your your the feelings of the character
and then
let them interpret that and make that
physical
right if that makes sense yeah because
you talked about the
like a high emotional iq yes
yeah in an intellect but all of
emotional intellect as well yeah
absolutely and so
being sensitive to that and also knowing
that they're going to be able to take it
and and you don't have to kind of like
spell it out yeah yeah you don't you
don't have to spell it out
you know say the line this way because
of this
you know just say this is what the
character is going through this is at
this moment
if you have to be a logical director and
say all right we're at we're at the
midpoint of the film this is the biggest
revelation this is an explosion this is
something big happening all right your
characters come this far
in this moment we need to exemplify
those feelings
right if i need you to go bigger i'll
say go bigger if i need you to go
smaller go smaller
whatever but uh trust that your actors
can can speak emotional languages
and and that they will then translate
that into a physical
action or being a presence um but but
be concise be clear uh
and just be be confident you know
because know that
know that you're the director and that
they're looking to you
for for advice give them notes give them
note the actors love getting notes
and if you don't have any that's fine
too but just make sure that the notes
are
are i love getting you know they're
emotionally based
feel this because of this or or what do
you think
happens here you know i think this
happens because of this
and then just let them translate that
what if you have to have a conversation
that
it's not a negative but it's more it's
not something that you want to do in
front of the whole
cast yeah oh that's good that's good um
so if it's a more sensitive issue
um you can simply pull the actor aside
um
because you're the director sorry let's
discuss this we have this here
um i need to clarify some things or i
need you to
clarify something what's on your mind
why aren't you getting to this beat why
aren't you hitting this this emotional
moment
what's what's going on in your mind and
work work through it you want to be a
psychologist in a way
you really do because sometimes you have
to you have to help them understand and
discover the characters because as a
director you should know them
as well as them right um and the story
so
as long as you pull them aside gently
say hey what's going on what are you
feeling or
is there something blocking you um if so
what is it how can i help you
break that do i need to give you
something different can can we motivate
you different way
and and you'll start talking those
things out and then
go into the scene with the people and
work through it um i always did that i
never
never gave a note in public i always
gave i pulled him aside really quick
could be the smallest note in the world
hey try it this way do this
do that and then they would go back into
it because i didn't want
to expose anybody's process you know i
want to be gentle about it so i
always pulled him aside and said hey
let's work this that's how i did it
and it works for me as an actor that way
so any director directs me knows that
pull me aside give me a couple thoughts
i'll throw my thoughts we'll work